hey everybody its Jessie and welcome to
live coding with Jessie and today we're
gonna do really basic stuff so we have
some HTML and we need to style it this
is within the context of our react app
but we're not really going to do any
react stuff today so if you're here for
react and you're used to the react stuff
then you might be disappointed but this
should be a great stream for beginners
because normally if you're interested in
web development you start out learning
HTML and CSS so if you're in that that
area of just just starting out then
stick around for this video and if
you're a little bit more advanced in
that area it would still be cool to
stick around and help answer some
questions in the live chat from some of
the newer people and you never know I'll
probably mess something up so help is
always appreciated
ok so I think I do have a meeting about
this site that I will be creating in the
stream in an hour and a half so I'm just
gonna try to do two Pomodoro sessions
and some question and answer and then
finish up so we do have kind of a cap we
can't go longer than I'd say are in 15
minutes that should give me enough time
to get ready and get to my meeting okay
so we have a good number of viewers so
there may be some new people let me just
explain briefly how this is going to go
so I'm about to start a Pomodoro timer
it's a 25-minute session we're gonna
code for 25 minutes and then I'm going
to take a five minute break and check
out the live chat answer any questions
that you have in the
then I'm going to do another 25-minute
session of code and then after that I'm
gonna answer all the questions in the
live chat so if you ask a question in
the chat and I haven't got to it yet
just hang on
and I will get to it before the stream
is over and then if you can't stick
around for the whole stream don't worry
about it you can wash it later on it
will be available here on the free code
camp YouTube channel there's more
information in the description like
links to the github repo and I don't
know what else I have in there I guess
there's a lot of stuff I always just
copy and paste it so I don't even know
what I have in there but there are some
helpful links in there okay so let's
start this up and then I'm gonna go over
here to my editor I happen to be using
Visual Studio code sometimes I use Adam
but today I'm using Visual Studio code
and I'm gonna shrink this terminal just
a bit cuz we won't be using it too much
what I do want to do though is save what
I was just working on which is actually
a whole nother page react component so
it's not quite working but it's almost
there so I'm gonna save it now so we can
start fresh and make a nice git commit
at the end of the stream let me check
the status we're gonna add this file and
then I'm gonna leave a message so
and we'll check out what I've just done
here in a future stream I've already
brought in all that all the data into a
wordpress installation so we'll need to
do some styling for that page at some
point there we go whoa we've got a lot
of testing going on it's good all the
tests are passing I have not made a test
yet for this directory J yes it wouldn't
pass because it's not working but once
we get it working then we'll want to get
tests on it as well be very similar to
the tests we have for faculty J s okay
so let's get to some of our HTML and CSS
so this is our our react component we're
not really going to do anything at all
with this react component we're going to
be mostly working in dev tools and
chrome dev tools and then we're just
going to kind of copy over our Styles so
what I would like to do though is make a
new folder in our static file so I know
if you're if you're familiar with react
and you've done things with react this
is not at all the normal react way to do
things so if you're confused just hold
on for a few more minutes and it'll
become really obvious why we have to do
things this way okay so this is not
ideal I wouldn't normally want to do it
this way but everything is entirely
valid in terms of just regular HTML but
because of the timeframe where this site
has to be made live we're gonna I guess
kind of do things a little bit weird at
first to save time and then after we
launch it behind the scenes we're going
to clean everything up little by little
so that it'll be a smooth transition but
it'll buy us a lot more time to make
things right I do see a lot of activity
in the live chat so if you're just
joining a live chat I will take a break
after a little while and I'll answer all
the questions and the live chat so just
hang in there I'm not ignoring you at
least not for not forever all right so
let's make a new folder and you can also
do this from the command line
but if you're not that familiar with the
command line it might be easier to do it
like this new folder and we're gonna
call this styles and then within the
Styles folder we're gonna make a new
file and we're gonna call this faculty
dot CSS because that's the page that
we're gonna be on so it may make more
sense at some point to extract some of
the things we put in faculty out you
know up to a different set of CSS a
different file and then share it among
components but for now this this should
be good when I normally would like to
use sass instead of just plain CSS but
we don't have that set up yet for this
project so maybe we'll set it up later
but today it should be should actually
be better this way because it'll be more
basic for those of you who haven't
really gotten into sass alright so let
me bring over the site so you all can
see what we're starting with and what
we're starting with is just the very you
know basic basic of of sites HTML with
almost no styling so this is what we're
starting with we have this data which
doesn't look like much I know but what
what we have here behind the scenes is a
lot of structure to this data in terms
of the tags so we just need to style
those it'll probably be a good idea to
make these images actually work the
paths all broke when we transfer things
from one database to another so let me
make these images work first I'd hope to
have time to do this beforehand but I
got caught up with some other data so
just for this
I'm going to change I'm gonna manually
change the the files there
I'm gonna add
so on my other screen I'm just changing
the URLs for these images manually so
that they will point to the right place
so I believe we only have two images
okay let's update that and see if we
have images now there we go we have
images okay so one of these images is
supposed to be for a detailed view and
one is supposed to be for what they call
a ListView on the other site so we'll
just hide one of them for now eventually
we won't have to deal with two at all
but for right now I don't want to edit
the data too much because we have a lot
of data here and in any manual editing
we do is gonna end up taking a long time
if we want to duplicate that for
everything so for now let's just take
the smaller of the two images which I
believe is this image which there we go
and for the ListView image we want to
just hide that completely so that'll be
the first thing that we put here in our
CSS so let me make sure ListView image
ship all lowercase lists you image and
I'm gonna say display:none
okay you know what I forgot to actually
hook this in here let's do that as as
well let's see so my let me see for my
react people here what's the easiest way
right now for me to connect this to the
component from my static files
I'll check the the chat in just a minute
after delays over and see what would you
are saying but for now we could do okay
so yeah if you've never used chrome dev
tools before it's really good you can
inspect anything on a page and
manipulate it right here in your browser
and none of the changes are permanent if
you refresh the page they all go away
but it allows you to make a lot of
changes here really easily just to see
what they're like so that's kinda you
know what we're what we're gonna do for
it for this okay so I could see using
next head is probably the best way to go
according to Harshit so thank you all
right so let's go imports and this is
some react stuff so if you're not really
familiar with react don't worry about
this we're gonna go back to the normal
CSS here in a second let's see and we're
just doing this so that our CSS will be
applied to these this component which
controls that page so just have to do a
little bit of you know differently then
you know we normally would so let's see
if I can put
all right so within the head then can I
just put regular link tags I think I
think I can maybe we could do just
regular link - all right so we will do
that link is source for our link tag or
href I can never remember
I think it's an href yes we'll find out
in a second
okay so we have to do rail and HF thanks
thanks everyone in the live chat for
helping out with that okay so our href
is gonna be what do you got static where
we'll be at all right let's just try it
oops
so let's see
okay not working let's just inspect this
and see I imagine it has something to do
with the path
rayona saying add in type text/css okay
we'll add that in
all right let's check that out there
hmm
let's see let's check our sources see if
it'll tell us oops on your console okay
so that's definitely not the right path
thank
see the structure alright here's our
folder structure oh you know what it's
the wrong thing I didn't call it CSS of
course Stiles sorry about that everyone
my fault there we go now it works okay
great uh-huh all right so now whatever
styles we end up putting in our faculty
dot CSS will automatically be reflected
here okay wonderful all right so here's
I want this page to look that's kind of
move this about
so this title will want this to be much
larger so I guess let's start at the top
and work our way down from there so name
is the name of this tag let's see what
we want we definitely wants let's see
all right so this routes details
all right so I definitely know I want a
different font as well so let's just do
this on main we're gonna do font family
and Roboto and sans-serif as a backup
and there we go
alright so we got the font we want now
let's work on our title alright sorry
our name alright so let's do font size
what do we want
let's try 24 pix we'll see how that
looks okay I like that 24 looks good
this is going to be pretty experimental
as well as we're going through since we
have to work with an HTML structure that
we didn't create ourselves we're just
gonna have to try some things out which
i think is kind of fun it's not the
fastest way to do things but it is
interesting all right so let's let's
throw this in under our name and
one good thing about this is all these
custom HTML tags are named you know very
nicely it makes sense the way they're
named we probably should have this in
some sort of container so let's see
let's see what container class we're
using here I assume we're using
something here right alright let's check
it out yet
unikz
alright yeah let's put in a grid
container in here
make sure went for the entire thing
yeah we'll start out with a grid
container we won't need to pull this in
I send grid so sorry I said I wasn't
gonna do too much with react but yes we
will be doing a bit with react
so all this is going to do what it
should do is give us some nicer margins
and I believe it made them worse okay I
think maybe we need to wrap these in
some grid items as well
yeah let's try putting this and a good
eye on him you know what I think we did
a some inline Styles that
hmm
all right let's let's go back to our CSS
for now and let's do this first we
getting this expected a different
indentation all right there we go let's
go I don't thought it was great item
okay it's like this
Oh
there we go so for for those of you who
are interested in you know kind of why
we're doing this and react we're using
materialized or I'm sorry material UI
the beta version of material UI for
these components and see I've messed
something up let's see see how bad it
messed it up
okay not terribly but why am I doing
this
oh no I guess this is just the regular
colors I'm not used to this color scheme
it was supposed to be the same color
scheme I use for Adam but I think there
are some differences there we go how
hard should sing in the live chat to use
format on save
I will probably use that I don't since I
don't have a lot of time on this dream
I'll I'm not gonna switch it right now
but I will use that later on okay so
that little distraction I had with using
grid actually didn't do anything but
let's see I guess
hmm
I guess it's okay for now
hmm okay
all right so let's look at what else we
have here I do want to put I want to
find the container I guess this would be
at this this container here for the
tests or even main I suppose we could do
it on main all right so let's go to it
our main here and try to put in a you
see these margin he's some sort of
padding or margin maybe I don't want to
do it on main let's just do it on this
content if
margin and we just want seeing pixels
alright that's fine for now I just
wanted to get it off of the very edge of
the page where I'm gonna have to think
up some other way but I'd like to maybe
do it within this grid system I also
have to check out the documentation I
suppose but I don't want to get into it
right now because I've said that this is
going to be you know mostly regular HTML
CSS and that would be getting into more
of the material UI react components so I
don't want to get into that right now so
let's just do this on our CSS so we're
gonna make get rid of that we have more
room and I can make this a bit bigger
okay so I'm not gonna do it on the main
let's do it and then we do and I want to
do its data test ID content okay
now we do this you know what it's not
like that it's like this alright so
we're gonna put in brackets and we're
gonna say what was that called again
data test ID
all right so this should select that I
think let's see if it does
interesting I think he's just doing that
because I haven't put anything in here
and we're gonna add that margin 16
pixels there we go so let me make sure
that just worked before I try to explain
what's going on I don't want to explain
something that's wrong
let's do a refresher yep that was good
so what I've done here is I've selected
did you know the divs but I want to
specific tip so I only want the divs
where it has an attribute of data test
ID and that attribute equals content so
if you ever have an an HTML element that
has some type of custom attribute you
can grab that attribute use it to select
that div and and grab pretty much
anything you know any custom attribute
so that's kind of useful the syntax is
maybe a little bit different than you
normally use but you know it could be
like I said it could be with anything
the only thing you do is you use these
square brackets the first item if you
just type it out as normal equals and
then the second part after the equal
sign is you're going to want to put that
in single or double quotes all right so
now we can move on and I think I don't
mind it being
I don't mind it being like this on a
small screen but on a large screen I'd
very much like to take up more space and
kind of have things side by side so I'm
okay with the name and the picture being
here but then maybe let's let's move
this other data up and make it kind of a
whole other owner the column you know if
we can alright so first let's inspect
this and let's figure out if we have
something that kind of goes around the
whole thing I don't know that we do
mm-hm
well that route component goes around
quite a lot of it hmm
let's do that then let's put the root
component we'll keep it that's that's
actually really weird that's that's very
odd how it how it was assembled in there
because the title for this section is
within that root component but then the
data for that the rest of the content
for that section is down here outside of
it all right there's some interesting
markup here it's gonna be a little bit
more difficult to do what I want I'm not
sure with this F is just hanging out
here what is this
well I guess we'll we'll figure out
where it's from at some point and get
rid of it there we go
details type F all right let's get rid
of that as well so we're gonna want
details type to display none let's just
add it on here so if you're doing you
know CSS and you want to apply the same
style some more than one element you can
do that just with a comma and a space in
between so we should if we refresh you
shouldn't see that F anymore great so we
don't see that F okay again if you
didn't if you weren't here from the
beginning we didn't create this HTML
we're kind of stuck with it at first so
that's why we're kind of doing some
weird things here but realistically on
the job you may get stuck with some
markup that you have no control over and
you just have to do the best you can
with what you've been given that's
happened to me quite a lot as a
front-end developer so I know it would
be better if we could do it differently
and change the markup but you can't
always do that okay so now let's take
CV link interesting not exactly the best
title we may have to come up with some
creative way to change this I'm gonna
think about that right here this is a
link to you know curriculum vitae PDF I
hope it's a PDF it is but you wouldn't
really know that right off the bat so
we're gonna need to add something in
here and maybe change the title okay so
this phone number I want it up closer to
the picture so hopefully it's in yes/no
right we can't I think we're just gonna
have to bring everything over huh
hmm
all right new plan let's try to get it
to where all these details are
automatically open and see how much
we're dealing with before I decide on
what columns were using so you can see
in this case we do have quite a lot of
information so let's let's work with
that first the mark-up it's just making
it a little difficult to really do the
columns let want so we still may be able
to do it but I'd rather do do something
first that I know needs done all right
so wow these details with changes
so as long as they have open on them
it's okay
I guess so
we're gonna need some hmm
hmm we need to change this
okay hard [ __ ] sorry I just I just saw
that I you are talking about using end
rot yeah let's get and rock up and
running
let me find my sermon all right Sarah I
thought I had in grukk open already I
guess I didn't
okay
inside shoot I can't remember house
there we go
nope
3000 okay all right I'm gonna paste a
link here into the live chat if you
follow that link you'll be able to see
what I'm seeing so you'll want to go I'm
gonna paste in the where I'm at so after
n Drock after the the Enduro part you're
gonna want to add what I've just pasted
in as well so slash faculty slash Haney
- Eric
so you just copy and paste it right
there all right so I think the best
thing to do now would be to add some
logic and art component hmm so odd okay
and my timer is up and I have no idea
how long it's been up I I was focused
and I didn't even hear it okay I will
take a short break now and go to the
live chat see what questions are there
and then we'll continue on after that
and we may need to cut the second
session short second code session short
since we went long on the first one I'm
gonna scroll all the way up to the top
of the live chat and just get it to as
many questions as I can
Manoj says should i and sorry if I
mispronounced that please let me know
how to pronounce it properly so should I
learn J s or TS so I'm assuming
JavaScript or typescript if you're gonna
go for something first I would learn
JavaScript first but I I have no
experience at all with with typescript
so you may want to talk to somebody who
uses typescript to get another opinion
on that
nobody was said in response to that you
can learn typescript because typescript
has some advanced program that can
convert it into JavaScript so that
that's cool it the only I would say to
that I guess is uh since javascript is
way more widely used in typescript
knowing JavaScript will help you to be
able to read other people's code and
contribute to their codebase more easily
so it does kind of depending on what
kind of work you see yourself doing if
it's all new stuff or you kind of have
control over what goes into it then you
know use whatever you want but if you'd
like to get involved in existing
projects JavaScript might be better for
you
Veneto says I'm a front-end developer
from Brazil and other countries do they
accept foreigners well I mean it just
depends on the country and on the place
so like I'm from the United States even
within the United States it would depend
on where you are within the country as
to whether or not foreigners are
accepted well there are some areas of
the country where they're very you know
accepted and other areas of the country
where you know not so much and I imagine
other countries are the same it just it
just kind of depends on on where you're
at so it's kind of a difficult question
to answer like you know in general
across the board but even in you know in
my university where I work we do have
some employees who have come from other
countries just you know to work here and
as far as I know they you know
everything's going pretty well for him
I'm not I don't know about you know the
outside of of the workplace how things
go for them but at least within the
workplace you know the university that I
work for is pretty open to that
my note says very confused between
angular react and view I I guess there
are definite differences I don't really
think I can I can really do a great job
of explaining all the differences to you
but I think the best way to really get a
good idea is to do like the basic hello
world example for react angular and view
it will shouldn't take you too long and
then you'll get at least a little idea
of what each one is like you certainly
won't be anywhere near experienced in in
any of them but maybe you just kind of
see what it's like and then maybe watch
some videos of people doing something a
little bit more advanced with each one
that way you don't have to spend a ton
of time learning you know before you
make your decision but you might be able
to make a more informed decision on
which one you'd like to learn more last
question
no BRS why don't you use sass I think
that's very logical for styling Dom and
it looks like reggae already says said
the answer but basically it's I just
didn't have sass set up yet so for sass
you need to be able to you know compile
that into regular CSS so once I get that
set up I would much rather you sass I
prefer that but at least for now we're
just doing regular CSS okay so I'm gonna
make a note of where I've left off at
and we're gonna do some more coding
so here's what I'm gonna do since I have
a lot in the live chat I'm gonna plan on
taking a good bit of time to to answer
the questions so this next session I'm
just gonna do a 10-minute session for
coding and then see where we are
Harshit says it looked like and rock is
crashed I'm not sure I'm seeing let me
check this as well we're seeing a lot of
activity you know looking like it didn't
crash but let's see okay it's still
working for me
yeah okay it's still working for me so I
don't maybe try to refresh the browser
or go back to it
I did go to a faculty page and it worked
make sure everything's spelled correctly
so let me I'm gonna paste the complete
link in right now so this link right now
is working for me no it's not when I
click from within there it doesn't work
interesting what's the difference
that's odd that's really odd
I just typed in the faculty members name
and and see if you can just copy and
paste that in because for some reason it
doesn't work with the link but it does
work when I type it in manually so I
don't know all right
Harshit says maybe it's because we're
using the development build right now
yeah it's entirely possible that that's
that's why it's not working okay so
let's get a bit more done here
and okay so we want to get these details
off you I've actually never used the
details HTML element this is the first
time I've ever seen it so I'm not sure
it looks like there is some default
activity here in that it automatically
shows details and it automatically has
this open close action going on so we
really don't want that I don't think
there's that much data that we really
need the open and close stuff going on
so actually this one might be long yeah
that might be a bit longer but and
that's that's going to need some work on
the formatting but for now at least
let's let's change these details and
everywhere where we have a details tag
we need to change that I guess just to
the div let's give it a div with the
class
I thought we maybe could give it a class
details but now that I think about it we
really don't even need that okay rook
rook says so it's a basic HTML element
thanks
yeah that's the more I look at it the
more I think it's got to be a basic HTML
element right so like I said I've never
seen it before but it that's how it
behaves so unfortunately I don't think
we're going to be able to use CSS for
this one we're gonna have to use a
little bit of JavaScript so let's see
let's go back to our component here
our faculty ojs component and let's see
what we can do
so this is all gonna come to us as a
string right yeah it's all gonna be a
string let's see if we can if we can do
something so let's say format content
all right so let me do a bit of
JavaScript here so what we've done here
we're just gonna make a function here
and we're using an arrow function okay
and that's because we want to have
proper access to the word this in here
so let's go within here we're gonna want
to grab this data now within here we
already have
we've already grabbed this props but we
don't do it outside of here so we need
to start with this props
okay and I say is asking can anyone see
my my chat Isaiah I do I see your chat
okay it's that do to render okay harsh
it's saying you can use a regular
expression to do it in render that's
true oh [ __ ] I was kind of thinking that
we may have some other things that we
want to change so I would just make this
function be where we make all those
changes but I'm certainly open to other
ideas also I was going to do like a you
know like a fine because I'm not great
with regular expressions but at some
point we could certainly change it if it
would make the code more concise let's
see it's new definitely interesting
content we're gonna want to
okay rook work pasted some helpful
information from MD n which is the
Mozilla developer Network I'm gonna read
this out just since you know we were
talking about what kind of tag that
details tag was it says details is used
to create a disclosure widget in which
information is visible only when the
widget is toggled into an open State a
summary or label can be provided using
the summary elements interesting
interesting okay
let's see
okay I'm gonna have to look up the
syntax on replace I can't even remember
the last time I used it all right so
let's go
all right so dot replace it looks like
the first thing the first string is what
we are looking for in the second one is
what we want to replace what if we want
to do multiple things at once can you do
that
all right I don't want double quotes in
my thinking all right let's go with
actually can do this but say what did we
want details
yeah when workplace details globally so
we want to get all of the details
replaced and we want to replace that
with div and let's just say class equals
double quotes here class equals details
that way I'll be able to tell which
which ones we've actually changed like
that easily let's see if that'll work
don't do this I what about closing tag
yeah hard [ __ ] that's what
yeah the closing tag will be missed so
that's why I was asking if we could do
two things at once otherwise I'm just
gonna have to do content replaced twice
in a row so it looks like in the
documentation I'm not seeing let's see
blue house car oh here we go we can do
no we can't
I'm not seeing a way that I could I can
get multiple things and replace them all
with the same thing but I'm not seeing
in documentation where I can get
multiple things and then replace them
with multiple things
so I mean potentially potentially we
could do this
you may need whoops stasis oh no this is
not give you get we need to escape that
we escaped
okay harsh it's has some code that that
may work here so let's check that out if
you haven't haven't watched before harsh
it here as a member of the community he
watches the streams and contributes
quite a bit of a really good code so
when I say hardship that's what that's
who I'm talking about
so I'm gonna check what he has going on
here
okay I should I see what you've done the
only problem I have with that though is
what if the word details is also
contained in there and I don't want to
change the word details that's why I've
added in you know this and as well as
this one
the thing is though I'm gonna need to
escape that so let me I'll bring this
over quickly just to see so so harsh
it's will definitely work
Harshit solution here so we're replacing
all instances of details with div but
what I'm saying is what if you know what
if in here in in these paragraphs what
if the word details was inside of here
that would then get replaced with div
and we certainly don't want that
okay we're probably gonna wrap this up
soon and I just got a notification that
my meeting is in 30 minutes I do have to
walk somewhere else on campus so I need
to allow for time for that
okay so let me let's go back to whoops
my timer did go off all right you know
what I'm gonna go to live chat because I
promised earlier that I'll get through
all the questions in the live chat so
Harshit said that he's gonna work on
this what we were just working on here
to be able to make sure that it replaces
only the detail tags and nothing else
so okay our should says it's fixed so
let me check that out now okay wonderful
wonderful
all right so let's let's use this now
I'm gonna copy and paste here what what
are should has done hard should
understand it like that because that's
definitely going to be a lot faster than
the pool requests been merging the pool
requests suspect what did I do wrong did
I put this in the wrong spot
I did not put it in the wrong spot maybe
I just don't okay so it looks like a
double quote there we go so we needed
one more double quotes okay wonderful
eagle-eye forgotten equals thanks hard
[ __ ]
why oh well sometimes that happens stuff
you do all the time and it's just like
you forget so why alright what's it
saying now expected comma somewhere
and it's expecting that a space is
required after comma there we go
all right great date is not the fun and
content is assigned a value but never
used okay okay I see how heart heart
should also did this a bit differently
so let's see
so I should put this here so let's do
that
this is last thing we'll do and then
we'll finish up okay so if you're not
familiar with Const it's the same it
fulfills the same function in this case
as if we were to use their VAR so I'm
not going to get into the details of
what's different about cost but that's
basically what we're doing we're just
declaring a variable and now we're
taking that data we had before but now
we're replacing some of the bits of data
and putting in some some different
things so now we don't need this anymore
so that's nice that that got rid of a
lot of extra lines that we didn't need
wait a second we need data ok are we
inside we're not inside that render
anymore are we no we're not so
not here not there not there it won't
work so hard saying it won't work so
things have changed
oh yeah I need to see this file the
whole file it's not showing me the whole
file right now what I'm looking at
oh okay I see so harsh it has changed
more than what we originally had oh I
see I see what I had messed up that was
the first that's what messed me up I
just saw a layout and in that okay all
right wonderful
and then within this we just need to put
content all right let's check that out
no oops that I forget in equals I did
all right
great all right so hmm
you know what
and don't think it words
in class the CRC toast
this has to be a casting cashing issue
food
let me try a different faculty member
okay Harshit think it's detail okay it's
detail and not details okay there we go
No
oops
well if it is caching I know it'll fix
it
just restart the server
okay that'll be the last thing I try and
then I I've got to get to the questions
or I'll never get through them all hmm
it's very odd
oh wait it's like it is details within
us
so actually we were right before it was
details with an S so let me say that and
refresh and let's just go with a
different faculty member
let's try we'll try someone different
there they're not gonna have a C they're
not gonna have a an image cuz I didn't
change it for anyone else let's try one
that's easy okay
Walker John that's easy oh it's still
the same details okay
I've gotta stop with with this I gotta
get to the live chat so I'm gonna have
to go fast as it is alright so let me
scroll up to I left off so if you are
new this happens I don't know if I'd say
frequently but it happens regularly that
we in fact don't get done what we wanted
to get done which is fine this is
supposed to be a portrayal of an
accurate portrayal of my work as a
front-end developer and things don't
always work out the way that I expect
them to so this will work out at some
point we'll just say it'll just take
longer than I thought
so unfortunately we won't be able to
solve it on today's stream but I'll
certainly if we figure it out before
tomorrow stream I'll certainly explain
it to everyone tomorrow alright so I'm
gonna do my best to get through this
all these questions if I happen to not
get to your question or a message just
ask me the same question in the comments
below this video or you can send me the
question on Twitter and I'll be happy to
answer later on ok
rehan a switch software I'm using I'm
using Visual Studio code
see
Jewell says too low hey how's it going
thanks for watching
no beer ass is is it free open source at
Visual Studio code is is free
someone says I should go now why is it
so boring coding is actually really cool
so I apologize if the stream is boring
it's probably entirely my fault so don't
don't blame the code blame me if you'd
like to give me some some helpful tips
you know some helpful advice on how I
can make this more exciting please let
me know I'm always trying to improve
Andrew Davis is is grid hard to learn
I'm having trouble understanding how it
works no beer says nope it's easy but
you have to practice it more and more
cool and I don't think I can improve on
that that answer that's you know that's
perfect as long as you practice it it'll
become like second nature and you'll be
able to use it you'll be able to use it
easily
gee Streak says the reason I don't watch
live streams I'm assuming I'm messed
something up at that point I don't
remember what was going on then but yeah
things do get messed up if that ain't in
fact was the case if that's the reason
then yeah it happens you can't there's
no editing on live streams things break
things don't work and you know you just
got to work through it but that's in a
sense the point of this live stream is
the value in it is seeing things break
and seeing how we work through it
okay no beer said when we use the CSS we
did not actually need the quotes around
content so I was mistaken I I guess I've
always thought that was necessary and I
was mistaken on that so I guess you
don't need you don't need that so thanks
for that no beer
I appreciate you pointing that out the
haulage on Hanson said yes he's going to
bring in be important I can feel it I
didn't have to bring it important well
not yet at least
I'm sure it will happen later on
a studio asks how many days a week do
you livestream I try to do five but
sometimes things happen like I meetings
or other things so I don't always get
five days a week but I do try Monday
through Friday actually yesterday I
didn't get a chance to stream that's
because we had someone else streaming so
go ahead and check that out I think it
was Ethan was live-streaming so sorry
about not streaming but it was kind of
in that same time period about a
normally stream and so you know I just
kind of watched his stream and commented
on there and so we're gonna do a better
job of trying to coordinate stream time
so hopefully we won't both try to stream
at the same time products geek says what
do you use to make the drop-down I'm
assuming you're talking about these
dropdowns here in the details and this
is just an HTML element if you use the
details element it automatically creates
this for you
which I just learned today so it seems
pretty useful if you're trying to keep
the site you know kind of really light
let's see Isaiah says hi hey my name is
Jose I'm 14 years old if you want to
check out my code pen it's Isaiah CT
wondering what projects I can make I
finish the port
I know HTML CSS j/s and basic Ruby and
Python this is my portfolio let's see
this is don't know okay so must not have
let Isaiah it usually doesn't let you
put in URLs if you put some spaces in
the URL usually it works if you want me
to see your portfolio feel free to
direct message me on Twitter or you
could just you know tag me on Twitter
with the link your portfolio I'd be
happy to check it out the question is
what's the best way for me to be able to
get my stuff seen
it's I guess it's tough to get your own
project seen out there unless you kind
of directly send it to different
companies as you know check out my
portfolio I'm looking for internships or
jobs or whatever otherwise you could
consider contributing to open source
projects and then that way you know your
your github profile will grow right and
your name will be out there for in these
other projects that people already look
at a lot so that's a good way to do it
as well I say it says where's the best
place to learn to make servers you know
what I I don't know that I'm the best to
answer that because I mainly do
front-end so some of the back-end people
what resources do you recommend for
Isaiah to be able to learn more about
about servers if you know any resources
let me know I wish I could answer that
question better but I guess I I'm
running out of time so maybe if I had a
little bit more time to think about it I
could come up with something but like I
said I usually if I have to do anything
with a server I look up the
documentation on digitalocean they have
good documentation and I just follow the
instructions
I say it says do you have any insight of
the new courses coming to free code can
my 14 year old brain needs more I
haven't seen that much of the new stuff
but from what I've seen it looks really
good so I'm excited about it I think I'm
gonna try some of the new stuff out when
it does come out as far as I know it's
supposed to come out around Christmas
time so sometime at the end of this
month hopefully it's on schedule but as
far as specifics I don't really know a
lot of specifics I know there's gonna be
some ex6 stuff in there I'm sorry
es6 in there there will be some more
react stuff some stuff with sass so
that's all I know for sure you can of
course check out all the new stuff
already if you want to you know check
out the free code camp github
repositories and you can see it all
Weinke even contribute if you'd like
alright Constantine S is that a valid
way to declare function no it wasn't a
valid way I just for some reason
completely forgot the right way to do an
arrow function even though we use them
here all the time on the stream so all
you know when I took it out so sorry but
anyway that yeah that in fact was the
wrong way to do it
let's see Duncan says may I request live
coding in Java I would not be the one to
be able to do live coding in Java
because my java skills are limited to
like a one day course that I took at
some point where we like kind of made a
game and that was years ago so I don't
remember any of it
so if someone else has some Java skills
and would like to livestream you know
maybe get in contact with Quincy maybe
on Twitter or something or send him an
email with maybe some examples of your
live coding which you've done before and
maybe he might be interested I don't
really make those decisions it's more up
to Quincy so I I can't say one way or
another whether whether you'd be able to
do it I just encourage you to you know
do some live coding on your own and then
you know share it with with Quincy
Quincy Larson is the the head of free
cookin
Matt says thanks for this Jessi great
learning experience
oh you're welcome I'm glad that this was
a good experience for you
Edwin says thanks for sharing man I had
a hard time trying to solve problems but
it's great to feel we're not alone
definitely not I have a hard time all
the time but it's part of the fun of it
it's always like a puzzle you know you
got to fix something and then once it
works it's awesome ok Harshit said a
resource for learning back-end is from
I'm at Corso Imad so see Imad tech matt
says Linda is also a good place to learn
about servers or udemy
harsh justice can I make some graph QL
tutorials for free code camp channels or
maybe some MongoDB stuff that would be
great like I said do do some stuff on
your own and then send it to Quincy or I
mean I could anyway I say probably the
best thing is make some videos first put
it on your own YouTube channel and then
we'll figure out who would free code
camp needs to check that out to prove it
to be on free code camps channel so
that's the first step then is just you
know make some content at first
oh okay let me see okay Harshit has
finally figured this out it was case
sensitive and we had to replace we had
to use a upper case let's see let's
replace details with details let's try
it one more time and then I really have
to go I'm afraid I'm going to be late
for my meeting my boss is gonna be at
this meeting so I really don't want to
be late
No is it still not working
no it's still not working
alright I'm definitely gonna have to
stop now so I'm not late for my meeting
so anyway thank you so much everyone for
watching I really appreciate all the
help that you had and all the you know
the awesome comments and everyone who
helped out you know some people ask some
questions in the live chat you all have
some great answers for them so really
appreciate that for everybody that
watched you know check check me out
later on in the week I'll be streaming
all this week hopefully if I'm not too
busy here at work and you can follow me
on Twitter I usually tweet about what
I'm gonna stream about earlier in the
day please follow the free code camp
YouTube channel and set notifications so
that you know whenever new videos come
out and new streams come on so most
likely I'll be back tomorrow with
another stream until then have a great
day